[Music]
[Applause]
ah
so it's true the neva massacre
i need to find this thomas guy and get
the hell out of here
hello anyone
thomas you there
hello
thomas
easy marianne it's just a good
old-fashioned
haunted hotel calm your ass down and
answer the bell
[Music]
so
you startled me i did didn't i
you look real scared
i'm sadness marianne
sadness is that your name
i mean you seem pretty cheerful to me
well it's what i remember
my friends used to call me by a
different name
but i don't remember what it was
your friends oh yeah i used to have
a lot of friends here
but they're all gone now
did something happen to them
uh i don't really want to talk about it
that that's okay
so do you live here
all by yourself
you wouldn't believe how boring it gets
sometimes
i can imagine
this place must have been oh yes
so busy people
coming and going
all the time always someone to play with
must have been nice it was
not anymore
so
tell me what happened i remember
people stopped coming only a few of them
stayed but
they became very sad
very angry they might hurt you
thanks that i can take care of myself
hey i was wondering have you seen
marianne yes
would you play with me just
for a little while it's been so
long since i played with anyone oh okay
okay
but i need your help first
yes yes
anything for a man thomas
do you know him uh
let me think uh i i've
heard that name before uh
take your time
[Music]
oh yeah the second floor
we can look there come on hurry wait
i can't go that way
[Music]
damn i need to get up there somehow
[Music]
hey an elevator
might as well see if it works
sadness i wished i knew her real name
[Music]
oh [ __ ] okay
marianne just take a deep breath and
let go
there a fuse box needs some energy to
spark it up
[Music]
gotta move fast an
out-of-body experience it's like taking
a plunge into nothingness
stay under for too long and it just
pulls you in
okay marianne now get your ghostly ass
back and
power up that elevator
[Music]
aha
[Music]
what the hell is this place
i oh [ __ ]
the cat it stayed on the other side
i'm stuck here
what's happening no no please mommy
oh god what happened to you
wait i know you you were that boy
bernard was it
he was trapped there just like i was
i knew his name but somehow that wasn't
enough to send him away
it was like a part of him was missing
so
all these people they weren't just
killed
their spirits were ripped apart
broken beyond repair
maybe i can find the one bernard's
missing
i need to look around
get off [ __ ]
gotta get rid of them a spirit well
i could use some of that energy
[Music]
burn you little [ __ ]
this was yours wasn't it bernard
it's about time you got it back
i'm sorry you had to go through all this
it's time for you to find peace
bernard thank you
huh it kind of looks like the one i used
to get through the mirror
feels like it too
[Music]
stay with me
yes yes
you made it marianne
what no no
[Music]
little girl
[Music]
uh
play with
the dress
where are you
[Music]
where you out
[Music]
there that's my way
or was it
wow